[Music]
I
calling I love to know the life of the
stuff I'm going to eat before it shows
up on my
plate that's why I'm in Canada's
Maritime Provinces and Quebec during the
season of bounty to connect with the
land and reach history through people
and
food good morning hi am mat ver how are
you I'm great than you Ox it's a region
famous for its gelic mikmar and Acadian
cultures and a bounty of Heritage farm
animals they are turning this place that
used to be a monoculture of corn into a
place of biodiversity bringing tons of
animals and trying to feed the ground
and create this virtuous cycle that will
bring more
life the skin is so
thin it's like caviar the idea is that
with so much biodiversity that we have
going on um it'll naturally take care of
[Music]
itself with the longest coastline in the
world Canada's communities in Nova kosia
and New Brunswick are depend dependent
on lobster fishing which makes up about
half of their Fisheries industry making
it a crucial source of Revenue and
cultural
Pride cuz down here in Cav we got the
best tasting Lobster in the world is
that so yeah there's 250 traps you lift
up all the traps every day put fresh
bait put them back into water so you
need to measure every Lobster to make
sure it's a legal one down here is 79 mm
and up the females with eggs you have to
throw them
back a good lobster fisherman yeah what
makes a good lobster fish you need to
have it right here you need to have luck
and need you passionate what you do and
you need to go out every day and do your
best I always love stories that deal
with people that are on the edge of
feeding in fully but are also very proud
of where they are
[Music]
standing visiting the ancestral
homelands of the MMO people along the
Miramichi
River is an opportunity to experience
the growing indigenous tourism industry
and connect with the land and history of
the region through the people who have
called it home for
centuries we got really really high
water today
yep cuz of all the rain yeah thr it out
let it fall let it fall and then let it
drift take your thumb and your hand and
you're just going to bring the rod up to
here yeah and then wait a split second
and then throw it
out
out it's good yeah it's your first cast
okay excellent then your heart starts
pounding good good boom boom boom boom
boom
this is wild mint and we use it as
medicine and smell it from here man
smell
that isn't that
beautiful these are tea berries and
they're they're very bitter a little bit
Yeah toward the end
M we want to have good foods we want to
have clean water clean air pass things
on to our kids and for a long time our
culture was denied that opportunity we
can finally stand up for ourselves and
we can be proud of who we are proud of
just living and surviving as migm people
here on the east coast of
Canada still there Mama M look at these
Beauties how are the Mustard Pickles
very
good Legend has it that the hopwell
rocks formed from the parts MMA people
once used to feast and celebrate with
walking on the seaf flow of the bear
fundi due to its famous extreme
variability in Tides it's easy to feel
the history and significance of this
land a quick flight and we're in Quebec
taking its name from the famous mon
Royal Park which overlooks the city
Montreal is one of the greenest cities
in the world for its
sustainability and its many green spaces
on top of the city's Convention Center
sits an unexpected
Farm I want to transform the city Farm
on the rooftop will have an impact for
biodiversity in downtown chard rainbow
chard
Tomatoes oh my
God
not have the energy to like really when
I'm doing a dish I'm looking like what's
the seasoned
vegetables the restaurant in Montreal
they want to work with Farms to stay
local you're going to get a live
reaction now are you afraid are you
scared no you're not yes I'm
stressed not at
all oh wow it's great that she's
focusing on seasonality in the dish
es meeting people and having meaningful
encounters is something that really
stays with me Canadians are defined as
being quote unquote nice I think they
have much more character than that there
is a sense of contemplation an
excitement to see that you can nurture
your soul nurture yourself nurture other
people and a love for their environment
that I really
[Music]
enjoyed